today we're talking about new
developments in the Bayonetta 3 drama
now before we get into the new info
here's a quick recap voice actor Helena
Taylor originally said she was offered
four thousand dollars to appear as the
voice of Bayonetta in Bayonetta 3. a
figure she said was insulting Taylor was
later replaced by veteran voice actor
Jennifer Hale and Platinum Games put out
a statement in support of Hale who
received a wave of criticism and
backlash after Taylor's claims went
viral Bloomberg published a report that
said she was offered around fifteen
thousand a figure Taylor has since
confirmed to be accurate in her new
Twitter thread Taylor said she was
initially offered ten thousand dollars
total to play Bayonetta in the third
game but she deemed it to be too low and
wrote a letter to bayonetta's director
asking him to pay her what she was worth
Taylor said quote I thought that as a
creative he would understand he replied
saying how much he valued my
contribution to the game and how much
the fans wanted me to voice the game she
added that Platinum Games offered her an
additional 5000 for a total of fifteen
thousand but she declined the offer
Taylor then explained quote I heard
nothing from them for 11 months then
they offered me a flat fee to voice some
lines for four thousand dollars the some
lines quote May pertain to the claim
from Bloomberg's report that Taylor was
offered a cameo role in Bayonetta 3
after she was replaced by hail Taylor
went on to say that she has been made
aware of what she describes as
ridiculous fictions about her contract
negotiations including that she asked
for two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars the Bloomberg report said Taylor
asked for a six-figure fee and residuals
to appear in Bayonetta 3. finally Taylor
said she was paid a total of three
thousand four hundred dollars for the
original Bayonetta and a little more for
the sequel Taylor also claimed multiple
times that the Bayonetta Series has
brought in 450 million dollars but
reporter Jason schreier who authored
Bloomberg's report characterized this
figure as quote fictional and frankly
absurd Bayonetta 3 Launches on October
28th as an exclusive for the Nintendo
switch and we've gotten everything to
know about the game dropping this week
on our channel so make sure to keep an
eye out for that another major release
coming out is God of War Ragnarok
unfortunately for fans who wanted to go
into the experience with fresh Eyes the
game is leaking ahead of time a Twitter
account is posting screenshots of the
game that contains spoilers according to
VGC which has seen the account the site
is guessing that the Twitter user
posting the images could be someone
reviewing the game codes were sent to
some press members last week who might
have forgotten to disable the screenshot
sharing whatever the case it's a
reminder to be extra mindful of spoilers
for Ragnarok and consider muting certain
words and phrases if you're worried
about spoilers I fall into that camp of
people who are worried about spoilers so
I will be doing just that in muting
certain words and phrases even though
technically a photo could pop up on my
time timeline without any type of like
God of War word associated with it
so I might have to just stay off Twitter
altogether let me know what you do to
avoid spoilers and what you think of the
stories today all together and how your
Mondays going unless you're watching
this on Tuesday already
I'll see you tomorrow
thank you